so excuse me we've got some geometry on
the board let's make this come one at
geometry because right now there are no
coordinates anywhere okay let's start
with the easy one again are we on for
time good let's just put some
coordinates on this guy let's suppose
that I was standing somewhere like I
don't know 1 comma negative 3 how many
steps did I ask you to be away from me 5
right so that would make this distance
here let's call that 5 units okay now
I'm going to introduce something a
little bit weird this is what one of the
particular things about this topic that
would be very hard pressed to just make
it up so I'm going to help you with that
see how I had the advantage of having
you guys twenty-four of you position
yourselves around okay I want to change
the metaphor a little bit imagine there
is just one of you and instead of 24
people all in different spots I want you
to imagine the one person just testing
out and moving around into those
different spots but following the same
rule that everyone else had okay so if
it's once one person moving around then
I'm going to call that one point that
can move a being that it can move I
can't just say it's coordinates are here
that's locked in that can't go anywhere
it's at 1 comma negative 3 it can't be
anywhere else so I'm going to need to
put on this a name that's variable I'm
just going to call the x coordinate X
and the y coordinate Y ok so I'm putting
pronumerals here to indicate the point P
can move right its variable it can't
move anywhere it has to move according
to this rule but it can be in a variety
of different positions okay so this is
number one okay we're going to do this
as a walkers question and introduce the
formal language around it
so I'm going to say let P be a point
that and I'm going to only exactly going
to take the language of that metaphor I
just gave you that moves it's a point
that moves such that it is now it's
always the same distance so we have a
single word that captures that starts
with an e equidistant so that it is
equidistant and I'm going to put five
units because that's the actual distance
I ask you guys to do from what were the
quarter is one negative three okay so
from here from this wordy statement here
I can write an equation right it's about
a distance it's about a distance and
when I'm thinking in terms of coordinate
geometry I have a formula for distance
right what's the formula for distance
what to start with a big square root
time this is the distance formula now
think you know what the distance formula
is in general terms but I have two
points here here and here so I don't
want just general x1 y1 all that kind of
thing I want the distance between these
two points so what's the first thing
going to be there's x1 there's x2 yeah
so x1 take away x2 will be as Lindy says
X minus 1 and the formula tells me I've
got to square that ok how does the rest
of the distance formula continue plus
why in this case there's a double
negative so watch out plus 3 it's wet
now
there's the distance that is the
distance between P and this fixed point
okay and apparently that distance is
always 5 so this should ring a bell
because back in year 10 when you first
encountered this equation of a circle
this is where we began we began with the
distance formula and you can see the
familiar form of the equation of a
circle comes straight out of this you
were doing lockers back then we just
didn't tell you that's what you were
doing ok
so that's very straightforward to
understand okay I think about number two
okay excuse me we need some coordinates
on these things I'm just gonna hijack
this one again one comma negative three
because I like at that point we need
another point so let's choose something
like say negative two comma one okay
that's easy enough now I want you to
think for a moment for number two how
would i phrase this I would say okay
there's some point that moves like this
guy over here again because it's moving
I'm going to have to give it coordinates
that indicate their variable so I just
call it X comma Y right it can't move
anywhere it has to be recorded to this
rule but it can move up and down to an
infinite set of points okay just like
number one kid I won't ask you to
rewrite this I want you to write this
except it's going to look different
isn't it because it's a different rule
it's a different set of set of
properties that this point now has to
obey so I'm going to give you a minute
to have a think what equation would you
write here that captures the way that P
can move in this situation as opposed to
this one take a minute if you come up
with something see where it leads you
like simplify it out and see what
happens and then for bonus points see if
you can actually draw for these
particular coordinates what it actually
looks like okay okay I've seen a couple
of you who have got an answer I'm sure
there are more but some of you are kind
of like I don't know this is weird and
confusing it's a whole new idea which is
totally fine so let me hold your hand
through this a little bit more have a
look at what I've written here do you
see that this algebraically states what
we verbally were trying to describe here
right the distance from your moving
point to here is this this is the
distance if I were to label these points
say a and B then this left-hand side
over here is PA
the distance from the moving point to
your fixed point on the right hand side
over here it's the distance from your
moving point to B which is your other
fixed point P a equals P B that's
literally what this says okay up the top
here I suppose you know center of a
circle what do we usually label the
center of a circle usually I usually Oh
when we're talking about this but it has
another meaning when you talk about this
right it's usually the origin so you're
got to be a little bit careful we're
trying to combine the best of both
worlds here so maybe if you called the
center of that circle something like say
I don't know m for the middle
you'd say P so the middle is gonna be 5
right that's that's what this says okay
now when you have a look at this you
look and you think this doesn't look fun
it looks like it's gonna be a disaster
but as far as much as you're showing
before you have to have a little faith
you have to have a little faith
sometimes because when you have a look
at what you're anticipating we're
supposed to get something really simple
out of this aren't we just a straight
line so therefore is there anything that
would indicate to me even though it
looks like it would be a dog's breakfast
actually it will come out quite nicely
can you take yeah good out of this
you're going to get a quadratic in X but
there's a matching quadratic in x over
here so that x squared terms should
exactly cancel and the same thing with
the Y Squared's so therefore help me out
here you're going to get this on the
Left what are you going to get on the
right can you tell me yep good yeah sure
that's fine same deal different order
okay so you can see this is canceled
City yeah you've got what do we just say
there's your x squared terms and there
are your Y squared terms so you're just
gonna get some linear terms in X and y
once you do that what do you get at the
end okay so I gave it to me same
has anyone got y equals MX plus B forms
anyone got that already or if you got it
in general form
give me general form general form of do
dot dot what have I got 6x yep
minus five was it yep good I've got some
nods okay that looks good and now
general form is fine but it's not as
good for actually working out what it
looks like you've got a couple of
alternatives what form would you like me
to put it in so it's easier to get a
picture okay so if it's y equals MX plus
B I'm gonna get 8y equals all this other
stuff so when you divide through that
looks like 3/4 X Y a minus 5 on 8 so
when you come over to your coordinate
axes and you actually draw the darn
thing 3/4 X minus 5 on 8 here's my very
small set of axes minus 5 on 8 is
between negative is between 0 and
negative 1 right so somewhere around
here 3/4 3/4 how would you describe that
gradient it's is it going up going down
let's go in up but it's not super steep
it's it's a fraction less than 1 so I'm
getting this kind of shape here right
and as you can see like we predicted if
you join up this interval then sure
enough it's the perpendicular bisector
okay